[Music]
you're gonna have to kill some evil
people that totally deserve to die
cause it's your destiny
hey
business or pleasure oh that's a great
question when you love what you do
it's such a hard one to answer really
wouldn't do that if i were you
i don't want to make it weird but
you and me
we're connected
told you this was gonna get weird
that's what i'm trying to tell you
it's like a ghost leech
i'm just trying to wrap my head around
what's going on
there's
i never thought a six-inch inseam would
turn me
[Music]
it you're the off killer
[Music]
what the hell
we have evidence it's time to put an end
to this
that monkey saved my life how do you
know he wasn't there to kill you
another hit on his list
he's one of the good
guys your code you're only going to kill
killers
do you really want to fight with one
hand tied behind your back
oh
i know you can use your feet too that's
not the goddamn point
he's here to protect us all
time to get bloody
two dudes
two fates
i don't know about you
but i'd watch the [ __ ] out of that
yeah i'm really enjoying the
conversation we're having just the back
and forth is incredible
[Music]
you